[Music]
really live Q&A so Juby start clapping
we're so excited you could join us on
twitter youtube facebook and periscope
and now we're gonna be joined by Conan
O'Brien here in a second but first we
start with the true stars of Conan
Berlin ah-ha-ha Flula Borg that's right
and writer Jesse Gaskell and writer Jose
Arroyo these are the people who have of
course of course
yeah these the people actually made the
episode funny and great and Conan just
kind of posted they built the red
Cadillac and he just got it or the small
was that small car so fun that's right
and make sure to watch the show tonight
at 10 9 central on TBS and this is
actually sudden because this is the
first time we've done a live Q&A or
people have not seen the episode yet oh
yes very cool very cool but these are
all spoiler these are all spoilers
welcome to the spoiler if it does Conan
live or die to this episode nobody knows
nobody knows but first of all Flula
let's quickly talk about what you're
wearing I love this man fashion icon
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
stay here tsehai to the Internet Conan
Internet which one is my camera that's I
mean they're both our cameras they're
all this is your show yeah welcome
Internet oh hello what are you drinking
there a nice beverage delicious liquid
okay
no it is warm in the morning very nice
very nice good to be here sorry I'm
running a little bit late that's okay
this is me pretty much without makeup a
light powder
sorry internet so Kona we're talking
about Kona in Berlin which is airing
tonight at 10:00 shouting again I'm
sorry I'm just very excited to see you
no you're not that's I could hear you I
parked my car about 600 yards from this
building and I could hear Erin Blair
yelling his questions ah
literally they were just excited emoji
spilling out of your face so it's all
calm down all right
sorry you seem calm I'm trying okay it's
all inside you know you've shut it down
shut it down what is the German word for
this snuffling puck okay coach coded how
did Conan Berlin come about how did you
decide to go to Berlin well we love
doing these travel shows we've been to a
lot of great places and always looking
for a reason to go to a new fun city a
place I've never been and Flula was on
the show and we hit it off right away we
did we did and and then Flula said you
must come to Berlin and I said I'd love
to come to Berlin that's really all I
need if you send me some snacks or just
ask me to go that's pretty much all I
need that an easy lay and so I said yes
and Berlin is a perfect City for us
because it's so different so much is
happening there right now it's so in the
news it is so vibrant it is really a big
player in the world scene and I thought
we got to go we got to check it out
awesome
actually somebody from Facebook asked
not to skip ahead but how would you rate
German beer oh I gotta tell you it's
fantastic that it is beer I mean I'm not
a connoisseur of beers what I'm just
telling you that it's beer and yes is it
better than Budweiser yes it's better
than Budweiser but I'm not gonna say
that I you know if I
we'll bar here in Los Angeles and ask
for a beer on tap would it taste vastly
inferior Germany Honam
I thought it was good beer so and
something else from facebook ass you
know what would you say your favorite
dish was in Berlin you guys had lunch
together as part of the episode
that was good what were some of your
favorites well it divorced I like all of
the booths we had some nice Schieffelin
which way for the right shoulder
shoulder of the piggy yes yes we do the
wrenched shoulder of the page yes a
[ __ ] shoulder some schnitzel of
course fun to say more fun to say than
it is to eat yes I have to say I loved
the sausages what do you call them I've
lost yes Horst
post-war any time worst of many types
what kinds of types of course we had I
should have this is a true thing Lula
has said to me that when I'm speaking
fake German and I know nothing of German
language but you've said about every
sixth word is I actually say something
yeah I've just said it is on I just said
it's on top of this you just said Oh God
which means on top of the store so we
are eating we are eating a service on
top of a 7-eleven yeah this moment yeah
yeah it's 18 to 33% you say real words
yeah hice is hot okay
yeah only his satchel gives the flu so
whoever I am hot with the flu hot with
the flu it's that easy to speak German
optional but always improving let me do
a quick shout out I know that flu has
probably made it all about himself he
doesn't suck the oxygen or shout but
Jesse Gaskell Jose Arroyo
they are the juggernaut or you gotta not
Luca no they are the head of the spear
they they go to these cities they do the
research and they really make it happen
I once again I have to applaud them they
are fearless they are intrepid they do
an amazing job and they make these shows
I think really happened and actually
somebody on Facebook actually asked and
this is for you guys did you find German
humor to be different than American and
how so oh wow we always do really well
when there's a good contrast for us
especially with because Conan
interacting one-on-one with people is
what really generates I think a lot of
our best moments and we had so many good
people they're good characters these
people are very comfortable being
themselves they're very like
self-assured and confident and I think
that that contrasts with Conan I think
Jesse's right that when we were at the
nude beach yeah one of the most
interesting things was the guy that
looks a lot like sting
there's we interact with someone he
looks like a nude sting sting and we had
a 36 hour tantric session yeah and sting
yes honey dead together yeah well he was
doing everything I was just watching he
show you his message and above all right
you know what is that no no doesn't help
to just open your mouth and afterwards
like I'm knockin around okay now listen
I'll get to you later all I'm saying is
that there's a nude man that we
encountered and he was
most comfortable person I've ever spoken
to and completely nude multiple penises
yeah I never felt more clothed in my
life I've just I need to be clothed so
he was literally my opposite I was
talking to my opposite in every way he
was German I'm this Irish American he is
nude I am clothed his BP is out your
peepee is inside okay no inadvertently
you said the right thing which is my
penis goes up into a cavity vagina
normally yeah the doctor said I was
raised as a boy we actually the show is
not aired yet but we do have a clip of
the nude beach so take a look right now
a quick clip of Conan and Flula feeling
uncomfortable in a new Beach this is the
first time I've been to a nude beach
okay whew that's a little strange I have
to say you look around and a lot of men
walking and they have their what are the
Germans call it penis Julie is that
always good to learn any language I mean
look you turn right there and there's a
man's ass we're looking right into that
man's ass and it's just you know like
have you seen I have seen it yes okay
[Laughter]
although you'll see plenty of me when I
go and visit a dominatrix
oh that's your show and I may have gone
too far in their sex artists I've ever
seen you go in any comedy you're
fearless in your comedy but that is
beyond anything I've ever seen you do
and I actually admired you because what
the audience won't see is tremendous so
you should go online if you hopefully
the web has extras and stuff you were
like Chuck Yeager of comedy just going
as far as you could now
I am a married man do you have not seen
this yet
well that's caused me problems alright
no evil marital chamber none that don't
already exist I think you're fine
hey Roy yo has the eyes I'm actually
squinting what what tell us about the
dummy
for those of us who haven't seen a
dominatrix in the room and at home what
was that like a great thing that I think
makes that segment kind of fascinating
is that the dominatrix is not there for
comedy she is not there to be in a
comedy scene she's there to do what she
does right I'm there for comedy and what
happens is she really does want to take
off all my clothes and put things into
me and I really don't want that to
happen and it's a the whole thing is a
battle she's trying to get and sometimes
she's winning and sometimes I'm pushing
back and it was kind of harrowing and my
teens was really frightened because they
kept trying to tell her this is for
comedy and she kept saying I don't care
yes I don't care who this man is I don't
care you know if he has a TV show I do
what I do she had a very German I think
sense of I must do my task now yes and
I'm trying to stop her and man it's and
it really hurt yes we didn't we actually
didn't determine a safe word I think in
advance I don't think she had one I
don't think she has this woman was going
to do what she was going to do and it
was terrifying and exhilarating at the
same time and I did learn a lot about
what I don't like sexually I learned a
lot about that nipple twisting just
hurts I know to be any I'm just giving
that I'm just putting that out there
if anyone's into that please tell me why
what it's all about because this woman
would do something that her
and then rub my back a little and see
see there's the pain but then the
pleasure can I say no just rub the back
don't don't do that
that really hurts no but it is both no I
understand now do you understand the
nipple twisting no it is a painful thing
but sometimes people like hey it's time
for pain no pains no gains just like the
film with Marcus Wahlberg and the rock
no it's the removi cause no pains no
gains yeah okay your boys in the hood oh
you betcha yeah and you just add a Z to
things it's a boy that's usually putting
junior shout out okay it's know dogs do
GZ I do not internally we always are
adding more SS and things right oh I
don't know what it was like here on the
state side okay all right very nice to
see what kind of TV do you get in did
you grow up watching in in Germany did
you see a lot of mr. Belvedere we see
all of the old times so I did see Gia's
for the first time in 1999 we did
receive it it's Norman Tobias you know
Norman's a man man is he I don't know
but he's boring he's not frizzy you're
singing of brassiere that's a different
thing
it's a Frasier well it's not
specification okay you're in our country
now I don't care what your pants say
[Laughter]
it's for looking a German word no but it
sounds it right it really does yeah it
sounds fantastic thank you oh is the
sound of German spoon makes when it
drops into a hot soup yes let's go get
it where my work is either terrible or
chilly Oh what's this a lasagna okay
Oh tell me what one of the fans asked
how fast did you drive in the Autobahn I
mean is it the OtterBox well it's the
out oh thank you thank you yes how fast
did you drive on me I think I went I
don't remember because they haven't
converted Garces yeah you guys would
know but what was my top speed 144 miles
an hour you yeah incredibly fast
yeah yes I went very fast I felt safe
the whole time because I was in a
beautiful BMW oh here we go
that's the BMW i8 now I don't have one
BMWs watching I'm gonna send me it's one
of the thing that the doors go up like
this and yeah and it's an amazing car
the BMW i8 I don't have one but but the
very motor works are you watching if
you're watching it you know they'll do
is they'll send me one plus a bill for
two that's how I get things in show
business something I give them shout-out
and they send it to me
with the bill and when I work it out
it's more than what I have the euro you
have the euro euro we have it we are so
made you miss the mark
I miss it the deutsche mark is so sad
what a great name to George watch mark
so clear what is it it's a mark it's a
mark of what's a seat times okay it's
not I all s about Germany after talking
to you a poem one of my favorite things
about going to Berlin yeah was that we
all started singing a lot of Falco we
sang a lot of fun because I've always
loved Falcom now use a lot of young
people out there like Woody's old
in talking about Falco look it up Falco
Rock Me Amadeus FA and co-founder cool
and he was great because he had that he
was falco and he would rap he's one of
the first yeah and only German rappers
of the 80s up to eight he sees the Kanye
West of Austria he was fantastic he's
not with us anymore he's passed on to
the other realm but shout out to Falco
go look at his videos and also 99
luftballons Nina I don't know I've
always wanted to me cuz I had a huge
crush on her I would love to meet Nina
she said we just muted all if you follow
team Team Coco on snapchat you could
actually see everyone Gemma got on the
bus to those songs because things got
things get a little loopy loopy on those
treated yeah we spent a lot of time
together watch it you can watch way too
much of us there's a lot of extras yeah
I think you can see me driving very fast
in a bun and 360 yes which is pretty
crazy you can see the urine spread and
the sheer speed going the Uranus is
pulled back and it actually turns into a
pretty good wine
you actually said the driver it's funny
because the driver who is a professional
obviously was you know 100% confident he
was driving but you said he got a little
he is a professional driver for BMW this
is
he does he is the clunk he's like a
fighter pilot yes and he was terrified
when I was driving and you could see it
I really I shouldn't be driving I should
not be seeing a dominatrix and I should
not be VM wi9 that's one thing that we
that one of my favorite parts of the
show is when I couldn't want to go make
a certain kind of sausage what
particular kind of sausage don't
remember what
blood sausage what's bluest blue and uh
and it tell us a little bit about that
the guy again it's all about finding the
right people and we went to MIT to this
he's a Marcus Marcus Spencer
Marcus Spencer he is at a master a
Meister yes Meister he is one of the
world's best sausage makers and he is
considered I think worldwide to be one
of the best and what's great about him
is that he again was very onto his task
and what's his job what loves his job
and again like the dominatrix he's just
doing his job and I'm doing everything I
can to ruin it
stop it to make it go wrong and that's
again you get the nice yeah then the
nice back-and-forth push-me pull-you of
him just having it's constantly feeding
you raw meat and you trying to yeah and
I didn't went out pretending not to take
it and at one point on camera you see
him realize that I've been cheating him
I think very disappointed but it was it
was fantastic it was really good and it
was again a nice dynamic it got very
creepy when he took me down to where the
sausage which is like half underground
in a weird look like it looked like a
scene from the first movie hostel it
looked like it all starts off with I
felt like a very pretty
co-ed traveling whose question that's
right I and we also did a little bit of
serious serious work there we went and
visited some refugees at Tempelhof and
was there what surprised you about going
to see all those great people there well
we wanted to you know whenever we go on
these trips obvious
the job number one is make comedy and
try and have a lot of fun and trying the
mission statement of these shows is I
really want those people laughing at me
I would like the joke to be near the
fool I'm the fool yeah which is pretty
easy but I like to try a lot of things
getting over my head and let people
laugh at me that is the goal of these
shows but another goal of these shows is
to also not sort of turn a blind eye to
what's really happening there and and
and I think we've so far been able to
capture that there was some really sweet
moments in the Cuba show in the Armenia
show when I went with Sona we at the
show ended with you know this was
actually one of the most powerful things
I've been associated with in my career
on television was going to the genocide
memorial with her and it was very real
we just rolled the cameras it wasn't and
and and experienced that and the same
thing with our trip to North Korea when
I went with Steven Yeun and went up to
the DMZ and you could just feel the raw
power of and sadness and tragedy of
what's happening there and you just let
it let that moment play for a second and
on this trip we wanted to Germany has
really led the way in the refugee crisis
and it's such I mean we taped this
episode in September I think and who
knew but with our election and and with
our president-elect this whole question
of others and the xenophobia and this
concern about you know who we don't want
these people too many of these kinds of
people and it was really fascinating
because Germany has led the way in
Europe and Angela Merkel I think
deserves a lot of credit she she invited
many refugees and took them in and
they're housed at Tempelhof Airport
which is this massive German Airport
which is now closed I think since the
late 80s or 90s and there's a lot of
refugees there and they're waiting to
maybe get better housing
somewhere in Europe or Germany and so
there were a ton of refugees there that
we met and talked to they had a group
that we spoke to and I think they were
from I'm trying to remember where they
were housed Stein and it was really
interesting because you get in a room
with them and very young men their kids
some of them yeah
and they're there you're with them and
you're like is this well we are in a
room with these people you they're
suddenly not those people they're just
they're not a label they're not a label
they're just I mean it sounds cliche but
we I spoke to them a little bit and they
just want to go back to their country
they just can't because if they do
they'll be killed and so they they very
much want their countries to heels that
they can go back there there's they
don't they're not their dream is not to
live someplace else they want to go back
to their homeland and they're really
remarkable people and they're sweet and
they're funny and we we ended up playing
badminton and and yeah some nice comedy
moments with them that were very natural
and then at the end they were destroying
me in badminton and they were cheering
and taunting me and it was nice it was
nice that they could beat up on me a
little bit and they immediately got the
humor of it and enjoyed it and so that
was that was a great moment yeah to put
kind of faces and names to to kind of a
situation is always kind of human as a
crisis is really great and we're gonna
kind of wrap up here very soon but I
just like to kind of go down the line
and say a few things that didn't maybe
make the show but were highlights of the
trip because again and we go in these
trips and they're just absolutely crazy
and we're working all the time but we
can't shove it all and do into a show
all right so were there any personal
highlights that you guys had aside from
hanging out with Conan Flula which is
always about Oh
comes outside of the Parliament building
and just then the president of the
Parliament buying a car oh yeah that's
right
Conan goes oh it's the president of
Parliament he'll probably want to speak
to me the car pulls out fast
and harder and then you just go so maybe
later car peels away that was that was
very fine and it is but a lot of the
great moments I think of me shows I kind
of to Jesse's point are unscripted
moments that just have happened yeah
like all of a sudden just bumped into
this rotor Kade and right I want to make
some moment out of it right absolutely
Jesse well I there's a clip you'll see
where Conan's trying to get into this
nightclub it's the Permian yeah yeah
it's the it's the most exclusive club in
Europe and I won't tell you whether he's
able to get in or not but we had some
fun going to nightclubs and there was
this that night club we went to with
Sato opera was one of the most amazing
clubs of everything it was like five
levels of rooms and there was one room
that was just like it was basically a
giant vagina that you walk Renate coda
played with a band called sato op yes
he's kind of like would you say how
would you describe this kiss my goth
mime craziness yeah and I was and
they're very they're very about gender
fluidity and there was a lot of grabbing
of my areas again welcome to Germany
yeah the nightclub scene was really fun
and I also love that Germans don't dance
with each other they stand all in lines
and face the DJ and that's true that's
true just it's more of like a concert
rather than yeah get down dance circles
yeah I believe you tried to dance with
somebody I did try I tried to dance with
a girl and and she literally just
wouldn't look at me which is typical so
that was fun it actually wasn't any
different absolutely Uwe Conant spent a
lot of time one-on-one together yeah a
lot of fans out there want to know what
is that like what is it like to spend
time with the man himself
well Conan is a busy busy bumblebee as
you guys say I'm so he was that no one
says a busy but no one it's a busy wasp
an occupied No Surrender I say well I
can tell you in the mornings so
Conan doesn't notice so I'm telling
everyone for the first time and you
dropped one of your hotel
he courts in the lobby and I picked it
up and so every morning I would because
I am adjusted to the time more quickly
than you I will go into your room did
you hear me whispering the song where
have all the Cowboy's that was you yeah
yeah 6:30 every morning why so and so
you would stand over my sleeping body
yes I started from two meters away and
every night I would improve by thirty
centimeters so you find a night we were
very close
thankless I had these are most amazing
dreams when I was in Berlin and now I
know why dr. Quinn Medicine Woman okay
you know I spent so much time with Flula
and there's a lot of it I mean there's a
lot of it it's on camera then there's a
lot of it it's not on camera but we
would just we would be walking around we
would we spend a lot of time there was a
roof bar a beer garden on the top of our
hotel and we would just hang out there
and and and have they had a special
drink they're heard of a Moscow Mule the
head of Berlin Mule
and it came in a copper Cup oh yeah and
we would drink those and look out at the
city I was a lot of drinking but it was
fun it was a really good time and Flula
is so much fun
sincerely just so much fun as you can
see to just hang out with he's like this
all the time and so there's about nine
hours that isn't even on camera of him
being really funny and we would just do
this nonsense with each other the
cameras aren't even rolling and we're
just going and I felt like well the
easiest show in the world would be if we
could just have like GoPros and it was
just fun I and we shot we could shoot
like thirty five hours and you know but
I really do feel like we would just roll
on everything you would never run out of
terrible clothes to wear and I know
that's a compliment he has an endless
supply of sweatshirts and t-shirts that
have kit yes opossum yes all of the
animals and also extinct enemas yes you
have not seen my brontosaurus jeans
you know true story I told you this but
when I was in college there was a kid
that showed up who was from Germany it
was an exchange student and his name was
Gregor
oh and this is a true story he showed up
I think junior year of college and he
showed up and I remembered you know this
is in the 1980s but he shows up and he
was wearing a pair of jeans I've never
seen before or since the jeans were
green except the crotch panel was a
bright yellow and he was and I remember
just thinking there's Gregor Gruber
wearing his green pants with what looked
like it was all just one pair of pants
but with the yellow crotch panel and it
blew my mind that I realized who's
probably your father he's out there
somewhere Gregor that are out there
reach out to me you were very nice I
remember he was very nice yeah I like
Gregor Cooper I'm not putting him down I
still hope you have those jeans because
I will buy them for soon and finally
YouTube somebody on YouTube asked
where's the next trip where are we
thinking of going next well we might as
well tell them now yeah what's here in
New York City it's the island of
Manhattan very exotic place where I
think there's very little footage we're
gonna go to the Chrysler Building
no we don't know where we're gonna go
yeah what are things that attract you to
to certain countries what are things
that excite you in the country as never
having been there I like never having
been there and I like there being a
strong contrast and so far everywhere
we've gone there's been a strong
contrast meaning I'm a fish out of water
and so you know I'm I don't fit in and
culturally physically whatever you want
to say and and so that that is what
attracts me yeah and so and I do think I
don't see why you only have to come
along to Berlin I do think why can't
even if I go to Guam please I can't
never be there I can't or at least make
an appearance
you know who is gonna be the Where's
Waldo of our traffic I swear to god it
even be a really good idea of just
wherever I am in the world if I'm in the
Arctic yeah if you have to look
carefully in the background even holding
a penguin you think so okay those pants
I feel so I would Peck these pants on
yeah I think you're always wearing those
pants under whatever pants you're
wearing just I'm a baggy Cathy worried
about you concerned about you well thank
you guys for joining us you could follow
Flula at Flula on Facebook Twitter
Instagram YouTube follow this man this
man is worth following he's funny please
watch Conan Berlin tonight
ten nine seven that's the whole point of
doing this and you just wallet boy come
on that's not pathetic member that you
enunciated go to watch Flula and then
the whole point of this is to get people
to watch the episode tonight guys mess
this up
Conan Berlin 10:00 p.m. 9 central on TBS
followed by an all-new Conan with Jake
Gyllenhaal Ronda Rousey and the Robert
Glasper Glasper experiment nada we're
gonna show tonight on the Conan that
airs after yes I'm gonna air a lot of
stuff that's not in the episode oh there
we go even more viewers
yes thumbs up you yes absolutely you get
paid for for none of it I love it
and you can also see all kinds of extra
goodies at Team Coco calm / Berlin as
well as the episode and thank you for
joining us everybody Hosea Rosie asked
Oh Flula Borg of course Conan O'Brien
thank you for joining us twitch you two
gotta wait Facebook and periscope follow
us on every social platform as you roll
up at Team Coco we will see you guys
tonight
Conan Berlin 10 p.m.
you